focused trained on the opponent's king
and okay there we have him mama jaroff
sits down he's ready and the armageddon
has started the final game of today and
uh the second day of the finals here we
go the queen's gambit again for the
third time we've seen today okay white
every time in the past magnus has
brought his night out does it again and
uh well shakira mama jarv is quite
persistent he chooses the same opening
he's done three times in a row yep so
just we've seen this position before
earlier today but now the first new move
black challenging white bishop and that
bishop runs away from a trade so this is
still very standard stuff just both
sides are now going to develop their
pieces uh mobilize them okay magnus is
the first one to go on the attack to ask
the questions of mahmoud that white pawn
push he's trying to push his f pawn
forward to trap black's bishop and we
see a trade of pawns now neither side
pausing for thought i think this has
been seen before i think this is still
relatively well known but it's
complicated black is temporarily a pawn
down black in return has opened up some
lines on the right side of the board and
now both kings are going to rush to the
other side both kings are going to try
and castle to the left
this
move poor move by mama jaroff is new
idea actually i mean previously black
had always been capturing a pawn that
was up for grabs that looks like yeah it
looks slow what mama jarov has done now
he's been forced to retreat his bishop
as well that is not a good sign he
sacrificed the pawn in order to get
dynamic active play and then he was
forced to retreat and black's queen
coming out will most likely be met by
white king castling away yeah
there we go okay so magnus ahead on the
on time and also ahead on material so
looking good yeah but mama jarov has
been playing relatively fast that's one
thing in his favor so the time advantage
was one minute at the start of the game
it's down to under 40 seconds now it's a
major asking questions he's pushed his
pawns forward he's trying to go for the
white king that's why magnus brings back
a piece to the defense just keeping the
white king nice and cozy nice and
comfortable black's king meanwhile
pretty much stranded in the center yeah
less manager of castles and copies
magnus castles on that left side okay
and he has copied and uh okay okay
magnus still a pawn up so if he can just
stabilize the position he'll be very
very happy but it's costing him a bit of
time he's not sure how to stabilize
i would want to maybe improve the white
rooks maybe you push one of the pawns
forward on the right side that's where
magnus has his pawn majority that's
where he has the advantage
and is there anything wrong with making
moves like take the pawn for instance
nothing wrong with that nothing wrong
with what i can trade a set of pawns i
have a feeling magnus won't okay and he
doesn't knight into the game yeah both
sides i expect at some point to see
their kings try and hide in the left
corner both kings will shuffle away to
safety eventually magnus first just
asking questions of mama jaroff
how is he going to deal with this knight
jump some pressure on his central pawns
now some pressure on his light squad
bishop for black yeah and uh okay well
okay
and tactics initiated yes chaos
initiated because black is attacking the
white queen and white did not move the
queen away white counterattacked against
the black queen and uh yeah if these
trades happen if both the queens
disappear magnus is simply going to be a
couple of pawns up magnus nodding his
head there slightly as well he thinks
he's got this one under control it does
look that way so knight takes knight
white's queen under fire temporarily
black is a piece up but white has a
selection of uh pieces to take to
recapture white for example can use his
knight and take that black knight in the
middle still attacking and
counter-attacking against the black
queen yeah
he can definitely do that and he's done
it and after bishop takes queen knight
takes queen check
my taste nights forced
yep so right now black's a piece up but
now no longer and look everything's
getting hoovered off all the capture is
white gives a nasty check that might
have been a surprise from mama jaroff
look at mamajara's face it was a
surprise he resigns magnus takes the win
wow and look at that reaction from
magnus cross and i wasn't sure if he was
digging the music or digging the victory
he is the winner of this magic magnus
carlton after a thrilling fight against
shakira and mamadiaran going all the way
to armageddon for magnus carlsen